et les victimes de cette catastrophe
restent profondément marqués c'est le
cas de pauline miranda devenue
présidente de l'association des
sinistrés du 21 septembre
bonsoir madame en viens de l'entendre
entre hbos soient madame merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france on vient
d'entendre entre 2016 et 2018 on
enregistrait donc 25 % d'accidents
supplémentaires sur les installations
classées 1 dans le même temps les
inspections de ces sites ont été divisés
par deux quel est votre sentiment
aujourd'hui qu'on n'a pas tiré les
leçons de cette catastrophe d'il ya 20
ans
absolument aucune aucune leçon nous ont
été tirées de cette catastrophe
malheureusement on le voit avec les
lignes du brésil et surtout on le voit
avec l'explosion de au liban à beyrouth
clairement aujourd'hui que vous évoque
ce vingtième anniversaire quel est votre
état d'esprit et l'état d'esprit des
proches de victimes ou des victimes
elles mêmes puisque a eu de 1600 baissé
c'est une journée très difficile très
émouvant très compliqué surtout victimes
c'est une journée quand qu'on ne peut
oublier
ça a été une journée effroyable une
journée d'horreur even tard après tous
ces souvenirs sont hélas encore 1 est
devenu un roman à jamais dans nos
mémoires 1 et
tout le temps on l'a entendu en
justice a été en partie rendu en tout
cas il ya eu des condamnations pour
grande paroisse la filiale de total
condamnation pour les dirigeants
également de de lusine pour vous la
justice a été rendue sur cette
catastrophe
oui ou non
oui on sait enfin que c'est le parfois
tu négligence et manquement que cette
usine a été
condamné pour nous c'est bien dommage
qu'une si petite peine d'amendé pour
grande paroisse parce que 225 mille
euros pour un groupe total et b c'est
une petite grandi
dans une botte de paille
la prison avec sursis pour monsieur
lucien maintenant il a 85 ans maintenant
qu'il fallait le condamner s'il fallait
leur donner vie bien plus tôt quand il
était plus jeune et que lui même à
signer avec une honda d'usiné avait pas
demande de manques dans son usine tout
était parfait
n'ont
pas traîné et est un déchet une poubelle
on entendait un salarié tout à l'heure
lors de la manifestation organisée par
la cgt dire il y avait des signaux à
l'époque on en parle et ça n'a pas été
pris en compte douze aujourd'hui la
colère des victimes
mais déjà nous toulousain à l'époque on
entend des tout le temps et on disait
souvent un jour à tdf pedra et c'est ce
qui s'est passé ce 21 septembre
pourquoi parce que cette usine était
défectueuse c'est cette usine n'étaient
pas
correctement
nettoyées n'était pas suffisant
impropre pour accueillir de tels
produits et s'il y avait eu peut-être un
peu plus d'argent pour les intérimaires
ou pour les sous traitants pour les
former pour leur dire attention si vous
mélangez tel produit des produits des
irish peut y avoir une catastrophe et b
malheureusement malheureusement le
budget n'était pas pour eux c'est les
examens l'envers ou rebours
pour laisser ses salariés là et c'est
justement pour ceux ci
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
qu'ils de l'argent pour les cadres de
l'argent pour born et d'autres personnes
fuient
vous avez dit en début d'interview les
leçons n'ont pas été tirées de cette
catastrophe
aujourd'hui quels sont vos demandes est
ce qu'il ya des approches en direction
de l'état au niveau de l'état qui a une
marge de manoeuvre pour agir
non non non y'a rien qui est conçu à
l'heure actuelle pour pour aménager des
sites seveso et c'est d'ailleurs en
continue à se battre pour que l' usine
au nord de toulouse soyeux
déplacer et c'est quand même quelque
chose aussi adieu un jour là c'est
pareil à cette usine dispose et de la
lande a explosé y aura là aussi beaucoup
de déchet et aura beaucoup de victimes
merci pauline miranda je rappelle que
vous êtes présidente de l'association
des victimes du 21 septembre merci
d'avoir été avec nous